Nos piden restar está loca expresión,
que se ve amenazadora,
pero si nos fijamos bien,
podremos hacer la resta
y simplificarla a su mínima expresión.
Para empezar podemos observar que aquí tenemos cuatro veces la raíz cuarta de 81 x a la quinta
menos 2 veces la raíz cuarta de "81x"
a la quinta,
tenemos entonces cuatro veces algo,
eso que estoy encerrando aquí en amarillo
y ese algo podrían ser caballos,
tenemos entonces,
cuatro veces algo,
a lo cual estamos restando dos veces,
exactamente ese mismo algo,
la raíz cuarta de "81x" a la quinta...
la raíz cuarta "81x" a la quinta,
si tengo cuatro de algo,
si tengo cuatro caballos
y le voy a restar dos caballos,
me van a quedar dos caballos
o si tengo cuatro de algo,
y le voy a restar dos veces algo
voy a terminar con dos veces ese algo,
y ese algo es la raíz
cuarta
de "81x" a la quinta.
Obtuve ese 2
simplemente restando los coeficientes,
cuatro veces algo menos dos veces algo,
es dos veces ese algo,
y eso por supuesto
menos
la raíz cuadrada principal...
la raíz cuadrada principal de "x" cúbica.
y ahora lo que me queda,
es simplificar los radicales,
en este caso, extraer la raíz cuarta,
mientras que en este caso de aquí,
extraer quizá la raíz cuadrada principal,
para empezar,
veamos si 81
es algo a la potencia cuarta,
o se puede extraer un factor de algo
elevado a la potencia cuarta,
saquemos los factores primos de 81,
81 es tres,
por 27,
27 es 3 por 9
y 9 es 3 por 3,
tenemos entonces que es,
3 por 3 por 3 por 3,
81, lo podemos escribir como,
3 a la cuarta,
lo cual es sumamente adecuado,
porque vamos sacar la raíz cuarta de eso.
Y "x" a la quinta
lo podemos escribir como el producto...
Déjame escribirlo por aquí,
para que no se me amontone,
entonces,
lo que tengo debajo éste radicales es,
3 a la cuarta que multiplica a...
"x" a la cuarta
por "x"
"x" a la quinta,
lo puedo escribir como,
"x" a la cuarta por "x"
y eso sería,
lo que tenemos bajo ese radical,
eso sería entonces,
la raíz cuarta
de 3 a la cuarta,
"x" a la cuarta, por,
¡no! no me voy a brincar pasos,
esto sería entonces
la raíz cuarta,
de 3 a la cuarta "x" a la cuarta,
por "x"
y claro esto
multiplicado por dos
y "x" al cubo,
puede escribirse
como "x" cuadrada por "x",
es decir, menos la raíz,
de "x" cuadrada por "x"
y lo escribí así
porque "x" cuadrada es un cuadrado perfecto
Ahora, ¿cómo simplificamos esto de aquí?
a estas alturas,
ya conoces este camino,
esto es lo mismo que
la raíz cuarta de 3 a la cuarta,
por la raíz cuarta de "x" a la cuarta,
por la raíz cuarta de "x"...
Hagamos eso entonces,
¿cuál es la raíz cuarta de 3 a la cuarta?
No, mejor déjame ponerlo aquí de manera explícita,
que es lo que vamos a hacer, entonces,
esto es lo mismo que la raíz cuarta...
no, la raíz cuarta...
no la raíz cúbica...
la raíz cuarta de 3 a la cuarta
por
la raíz cuarta de "x" a la cuarta,
por la raíz cuarta de "x"...
por la raíz cuarta de x
y por supuesto todo esto,
multiplicado por... 2,
y todo esto de aquí menos
la raíz cuadrada principal de "x" cuadrada,
por la raíz cuadrada principal de "x"
y esto, lo vamos a simplificar como...
aquí tenemos,
la raíz cuarta de 3 a la cuarta que es 3
simplemente 3,
luego la raíz cuarta de "x" la cuarta,
que es "x",
aunque, ahora que me acuerdo,
no es exactamente el valor de "x"
queremos la raíz cuarta principal
de "x" a la cuarta,
¿Qué pasaría si x es negativo?
No podemos obtener un valor negativo
como una raíz principal,
así que sin importar si
"x" es positivo o negativo
queremos que el resultado de esto sea positivo
y eso es precisamente
lo que hace el valor absoluto,
así es que, la raíz cuarta principal de "x" a la cuarta,
es, lo que vamos a obtener aquí es,
el valor absoluto de "x"...
el valor absoluto de "x"
y ahora,
bueno, siempre podrías tener el argumento
de que "x" tiene que ser positivo,
porque esto que tenemos aquí,
bajo el radical tiene que ser positivo,
si queremos que esto,
sea válido para los números reales,
pero bueno,
sigamos con el argumento que hemos usado aquí,
esto multiplicado
por la raíz cuarta principal de "x"
menos,
la raíz cuadrada principal de "x" cuadrada
que por el mismo razonamiento anterior,
esto es igual al valor
absoluto de "x",
que multiplica a la raíz cuadrada principal de "x".
Hagamos el producto entonces,
esto de aquí es 2 por 3,
vuelvo al absoluto de "x",
esto es 2 por 3 es igual a 6
por el valor absoluto de "x",
por, la raíz cuarta principal...
la raíz cuarta principal...
de "x"
y eso menos,
el valor absoluto de "x" que obtuvimos aquí,
el valor absoluto de "x"
por la raíz cuadrada principal de "x"
y ya no podemos simplificar más...
porque si te fijas,
aquí tenemos una raíz cuarta
y aquí tenemos una raíz cuadrada,
son de distinto orden,
si tuvieran el mismo orden estas dos raíces,
quizás podríamos simplificar aún más.
Así es que hemos concluido con la resta
y la hemos simplificado plenamente,
y si suponemos que esto tiene que estar definido,
para números reales,
tenemos que establecer que el dominio,
son las "x" positivas
las "x" mayor que 0,
para que estas raíces estén definidas,
si las "x" son mayor que 0,
no vamos a estar tratando con números imaginarios,
si los valores de "x" son positivos,
entonces podemos asumir
que el valor absoluto de "x" es igual a "x",
con esa restricción de dominio
podemos eliminar el valor absoluto.